this morning we're learning more about a
shelter that offers help to pregnant
women and mothers in crisis and how it
could expand after the supreme court
ruling on abortion saint mary's shelter
in virginia opened its doors 16 years
ago and says it has helped hundreds of
women john crawford looks at its mission
to quote ensure the health of mother and
baby jan good morning good morning that
you know mary shelter has several homes
it's faith-based but they take in women
regardless of their views now many of
the women were considering abortion but
mary shelter offers housing and help
getting on their feet with their
children for up to three years the
director told us it's not a solution for
everyone it's mainly for those
underserved women who feel they have
nowhere else to go
in 2014 shantae mallory lost her job she
had two young kids at home and couldn't
pay her rent when she got pregnant again
she decided to have an abortion it
wasn't what i wanted to do it was just
at the moment it was that's what
everybody was telling me to do so i feel
like that was really my only option then
she found out about mary's shelter it
changed my life it changed your life it
gave me a new start i didn't have to
give up or get rid of a child that i
knew i wanted
just because things got hard i didn't
have a support system
twenty-five-year-old logan wilkins also
found mary shelter in a moment of
hopelessness i also had a dumpster at my
job you're literally sleeping behind a
dumpster yes i was literally sleeping
behind a dumpster eight months pregnant
how were you able
well to survive it was really difficult
sorry
we turn no one away because we know that
their situation at that moment is just
that desperate kathleen wilson started
mary's shelter 16 years ago more than
300 women have come through their doors
some staying up to three years in fully
furnished shared homes and apartments
with their children we have another
kitchen upstairs they get parenting
training and help with employment and
housing when they leave here that
independent lifestyle becomes you know a
real viable reality for them as opposed
to just well you had the baby and you're
done which is not the way any of the
ministries i know work women come from
up and down the east coast to stay here
including a woman and her children who
arrived unannounced from florida the day
of our visit
wilson who opposes abortion say with
states now free to ban or restrict
abortion more women will need help but
pregnancy shelters are not for every
situation
are you concerned that women will be
forced into unwanted pregnancies
no i don't i mean i i think that there
will be some i hope that they'll reach
out to other agencies like maybe an
adoption agency or that families will
step up i think we'll have to increase
support groups for moms like those this
is not a solution for every woman
who potentially may not be able to have
an abortion right no not everybody needs
a home not everybody needs to move out
of their house not everybody needs to
leave a violent situation
but we can help those that are
having abortions because they feel
hopeless i had no motivation i didn't
have any kind of guidance
malory now 31 with five daughters says
mary shelter helped her find purpose i'm
in bible college studying for theology i
also am a peer recovery coach so i help
those that are battling with addictions
traumas from like sexual abuse or just
past traumas wilkins now a mother of
four returned to mary shelter for the
second time last december while pregnant
with her son leon he is three months old
i just got a new job
where in the career field that i want to
be in the medical field what are you
doing i am a scheduler but i'm getting
my medical billing and coding
certification in four months i should be
done in october what's the message of
your story that there is hope
that there are places around that that
can help you
that you know having abortion isn't the
final answer
what about you abortion isn't the final
answer there's so many other options and
to be quite honest it is literally all
worth it when you have that baby
now mary shelter gets his funding from
private donors and fundraising events
and the director told us that it's
helped open shelters in other states and
hopes to keep expanding tony
well jan it's a beautiful option for
women who want that option uh the key
thing is for the women who want it thank
you very much for your coverage
yesterday and also today janet continues
to be just absolutely superb
thank you thanks tony